well i guess it's time we start delving into
a new and brilliant story which so far has
really filled me with that joy you get when you
truly find a god-like series that you know is
literally going to mind-melt people when the
anime finally does release and honestly after
starting this series the absolute anticipation
for what mapper and their team is going to be
bringing us later this year has completely
and utterly multiplied an overall hype
the mangaka tatsuki fujimoto has honestly outdone
himself with this story even more than his last
one and i cannot wait to see what other titles he
may release in the future so without holding back
any more it's time to grab those melons and get
into the one and only world of chainsaw man in
this first video we will cover the first entire
arc of the story that being the introduction arc
so as the story starts off we find a
young dingy talking to his chainsaw-like
pet named pogita they continue talking bringing
up how tree cutting and selling his body parts
brings his debt down to only 38 million and 40 000
yen then she then turns to pachita saying let's go
and kill something straight after this we see that
he is hunting a tomato devil using pachita like a
chainsaw dingy explains that hunting a devil will
make him three hundred thousand dollars which will
help ease his debts for a birds after destroying
the devil then she talks to an elderly man
who tells him that the devil's worth on the
black market is four hundred thousand yen
however denji's happiness is soon dashed when the
old man tells him that after subtracting his debt
and other expenses from the total he only gets
70 000 yen then she then takes his money from the
old man and thinks to himself that after paying
his water bill he's only left with a measly 1800
and since denji and pachita have got nothing
to eat at home too their meal for the day will
be a single slice of succulent bread as this
was happening the old man and his driver were
watching him from a car the driver questions him
asking why did he employ brat as a devil hunter to
which the old man responds that he employed dingy
because his pops died before he paid back his debt
however the driver still persists and the old
man explains that a real devil hunter wouldn't
just let a yakuza take the corpse afterwards he
then adds on that the good thing about denji is
that he always does what he is told uncertain of
this the driver yells out and asks stingy to eat
a cigarette for a hundred yen which he accepts
because every penny matters to him as denji eats
a cigarette the driver speeds away laughing
and saying that they will reach out to him if
there's another devil appearance and he better
not run away because if he does they will find
and kill him upon them leaving dingy spits out
his ziggy and tells pochita that because of the
hundred yen they will be able to eat for another
three days later at denji's shack we see the duo
eating a slice of bread and saying that the
normal things in life are just a dream for him
he can't ask a girl over because of his run-down
shack and he heard that dating is quite expensive
anyway pogchita whines in response and then
she says that if dreams ever come true then he
wants to hug a girl before he dies as we flow back
into a flashback we see the kid denji standing in
front of his father's grave who had hung himself
before making his monthly payment to the yakuza
behind denji a younger but still old man tells
him to have the 700 000 yen ready by tomorrow or
he will cut up dingy and sell the pieces as the
car leaves we see pachita coming out from behind
a tree seemingly to attack dingy the young boy
though accepts his fate and tells the chainsaw
devil to kill him because he's going to die either
way but bachita doesn't attack him instead falling
to the ground showing dingy his wounds upon
seeing him dying denji remembers his late father
and decides he doesn't want anyone to die sitting
up he tells pachita to bite his arm because he
heard if a devil drinks blood its wounds are
healed and if bachita doesn't want to die he has
to do so vegeta bites his arm while denji screams
telling him that their blood doesn't come for free
and that this is a contract so in return for
saving him pachuda must also help to save denji as
he doesn't want to die either the next day the old
man shows up for the payment and as denji shows up
slaying a devil he asks the old man if he would
hire him as a devil hunter after the flashback
is over then she lays on the ground saying he
can't fall asleep because he is too hungry and
all he can think about is his debt he tells the
little pochita that he knows what he will dream of
tonight saying that he will flirt with a girl play
video games and fall asleep in her arms he tells
pegita that it's a pretty great dream to which the
pup yapped happily almost instantly though denji
spewed up blood while at the same time the old
man randomly started banging at the door saying
that there was a devil then she tells petita that
his mother died of a heart disease which made her
cough up blood as they leave dingy thinks to
himself wanting to just dream even a little
soon they arrive at the abandoned building with
the devilers then she questions the old man as
he doesn't see any kind of devil but the old man
acts like he didn't hear dingy and starts thanking
him for being loyal like a dog hearing this then
she starts feeling awkward however the old man
switches on him telling dingy that he hates
the stench of dogs sadly as dinji was looking
forwards he feels something pierced through his
heart from behind as he looks backwards he sees
the yakuza man with a short sword had stabbed
him and pochita through the heart the old man
tells dingy that they want power to make money so
they have made a contract with a devil like he did
revealing himself the monstrous devil stands up
with a bunch of abnormal looking humans around him
while saying that it wants the death of all devil
hunters he goes on to explain that he the zombie
devil has turned all of these stupid people
into his puppets by making them his zombies
it orders the zombies to kill him and soon enough
these zombies start chasing the injured duo
as he runs dingy thinks that he just wanted to
live a normal life but no one ever let him have
even that sadly they catch and kill him brutally
slicing him into multiple pieces and leaving his
remains in an alleyway dumpster as the blood from
dengi's nose reaches poaches mouth the young devil
thinks about how they were cutting trees and how
dingy had told him that if he dies fighting demons
he would be worried about what would happen to a
cheetah wondering if he would die of starvation or
get killed by another devil hunter though dingy
had said he had heard some devils can take over
dead humans bodies so if petita is one of them he
wants to give him his body and run away from the
town so that the yakuza won't come after him then
she says it'd be nice if you can have a normal
life and die a normal death while telling him to
fulfill his dreams for him back in reality denji's
body can torts out of place as it slowly gets
pulled back together by bochita who is connected
to his chest seemingly fusing with them inside of
denji's head he has a dream in which he is lying
with pachita on his chest denji calls pachita's
name to which pagida responds with a cheerful wolf
then denji asks him if he has taken over the
control of his body like he had asked him to
to which pachita responds by saying he has always
liked to listen to dingy's dreams then she is left
shocked but before he can say anything pachita
tells him that this is a contract and that he
will give denji his heart but in exchange
then she has to show him more of his dreams
he then snaps awake calling for pachita but then
he looks down and is shocked seeing that all of
his wounds are gone he then looks at his chest and
finds a cord protruding from his heart identical
to pachita's tail screaming he yells out for his
little friend's name in front of him though we see
that all of these zombies have returned again and
the zombie devil gets shocked seeing dingy somehow
had managed to survive against the previous
attack he instantly orders these zombies to
kill and devour dingy though just blankly stares
at the mob thinking that all these guys already
had enough and why did they want a better life
but then he wonders if he is similar and if he
should have been happy as long as he had pages
here but he still wanted a better life as well
he thinks to himself that dreaming is not a
bad thing everybody dreams and it's not bad too
but if they come in the way of his dreams then
they will have to die dingy rips the kill switch
on his chest harder than a damn blade blade and a
horde of zombies rush at denji and begin mauling
him the zombie devil pipes up saying to himself
and the horde the dingy has got to be dead after
they ate him but suddenly we see a zombie
being teared vertically apart by a chainsaw
dingy then reveals himself tearing through the
crowd of zombies fused with pochita to become
the one and only chainsaw man the zombie devil
tries to say to dingy that they are the same
but gets completely ignored and then she cuts
through its eye then continues to tear the devil
apart easily with his blades turning around he
notices the zombie horde have turned into devils
and since he is a devil hunter he's got to
destroy them all he literally starts slicing his
way through them one by one then laughing like an
actual madman as he ruthlessly takes out the rest
saying that if he kills every single one of them
then he can say goodbye to his debt a while later
a car pulls up outside of the abandoned building
and three people and suits come inside the girl
notes that it looks like someone has beaten us
to the punch as they realize that the entire
horde has been completely obliterated as they look
around and see only one remaining devil standing
there one of these suits says that they have got
a living one however the mysterious girl walks up
to denji and says that he has a peculiar smell it
isn't devil or human she then asks him if he did
all of this but instead denji was too worn out
and he begins to throw up blood from his mouth
while collapsing he asks the girl to hold him
but before he even realizes the girl hugs stingy
instead of holding him and dingy's
chainsaw form starts losing its solidity
seeing him like this the girl says that she knows
he's a human one of the suits ask the girl if he
is possessed by a devil to which she responds no
because you can see the possession on their faces
the girl then responds tell dingy who was in her
hands that she came here to kill the zombie devil
and as a public safety devil hunter she offers
dengy two choices that he can either be killed by
her as a devil or be kept by her as a pet human
she tells him as a pet he will get given food
in which then she asks her food and a little
surprised voice and what kind of food would he
get for breakfast the girl answers while thinking
that he can have bread with jam salad coffee and
even more hearing he would be getting bread with
jam though and other things for breakfast then she
agrees saying that it sounds like heaven before
collapsing as time moves forward we see that
denchi has woken up and is heading somewhere with
the devil hunters his stomach continues gurgling
and he says that he hasn't eaten to which the
girl responds that they haven't had breakfast
either so they might as well go and grab some food
upon hearing this denji awkwardly says that he's
broke and can't afford the food to which the
girl says that he can pick whatever he wants
and she will pay for it then she is left shocked
but before talking the girl gives dingy her code
saying he will draw people's attention walking
around shirtless after putting on the jacket then
she peeks over at the girl and thinks to himself
that people had always called him dirty and smelly
but with this girl it's the first time he's ever
been treated so nicely and on top of that by a
pretty girl as well with all this then she comes
to a realization that he truly is in love with her
soon they arrive at a shop where they order their
food but suddenly a random man runs in bleeding
and yelling at the cashier to help him the suit
girl tells him that she is a devil hunter and asks
him to explain what has happened the man screams
that a devil has kidnapped his daughter and taken
her into the woods at the same time the chef comes
up and then tells them that their udon is ready
to watch the girl thinks for a while and asks
stingy what his name is obviously denji tells her
his name and she tells him that she doesn't want
her udon to get soggy instead he will have to go
and kill the devil himself then she responds that
he's also having food though and while quietly
mumbling this he overhears one of the devil
hunters say that an extremely experienced devil
hunter is on the job cutting him off she then asks
dingy if he forgot that he is her pet and the only
response that she wants is a yes or a wolf as she
doesn't need a dog who says no then she asks what
she means in an unsure voice to what she intensely
says that she has heard from a judge that in the
crime division they euthanize useless dogs while
he's terrified denji stands there the girl tells
him to get to work fast before her noodles becomes
soggy and asks him what his answer was to which he
distraught dingy responds by saying yes as he
runs off into the woods thinking about how the
girl was nice to the point that he even liked her
a little however he now realizes that she is just
a damn psycho who is also treating him just like a
dog while thinking he gets reminded of pogisa and
how he had died then he suddenly hears the voice
of a girl he heads over to where the voice was
coming from and finds the girl he's after with
a little devil instantly after noticing him the
young girl confronts stingy asking him to let
the little devil go she proceeds to tell dingy
that her dad had beaten her up but this nice devil
came and saved her she pleads for him not to kill
it upon hearing this dingy starts thinking what
should he do and after a somewhat difficult
decision then she tells the girl that they all
three can run away if they want and he also had
a friendship with a devil so he knows that not
all devils are evil the girl asks didn't she if
they can really run to what she says that they
totally can however as the girl claps denshi's
hand and they all start laughing the girl's
face starts deforming slightly all of a sudden
dingy finds himself getting lifted up and looks
to find out that it's the devil's actual form
which are transformed into a terrifying worm-like
devil shocked then she wonders what the hell had
just happened and the devil tells him that he will
show him something cool before he dies and that
instead of a worm he's actually the muscle demon
he proceeds to manipulate denji's arm he says that
he can control muscles and taunts him even more
with the girl's mouth saying how you'll mess with
the little girl he begins messing with the girl's
face or mahinu cackle throughout his entire attack
however denji lets out a little giggle and
then rips his kill switch with his mouth
almost instantly decimating the muscle demon
with his chainsaws then she yells at the devil
then now he won't have a problem killing a low
life like him and while the devil screams in
agony denji finishes him off once and for all
by casting the muscle devil into multiple pieces
from a distance we see the girl eating her udon
and saying out loud that dingy sure is a useful
dog coming out of the woods tired while carrying
the girl on his back dingy responds with a wolf
before falling and collapsing the girl catches
him once again though and asks him if he's okay
denji thinks to himself that she smells good and
apologizes to her for falling as he accidentally
ended up cutting himself with a chainsaws and
because of that he continued to lose blood
until he fell she asks did she how did his body
even end up like this to which he responds that
his pet devil pochita had become his heart as he
continues explaining his disbelief and being alive
the girl tells him that historically speaking his
condition is extremely rare it's so rare that it
hasn't even been given a name nor confirmed but
she still says that she believes him because she
has an especially good nose which is able to tell
that his best friend is still alive inside of him
and that his body also has two sins one of a
human and one of a devil as he hears this then
she then blushes and his stomach starts to gurgle
again reminding him that he wants to eat that udon
the girl then asks him if he can feed himself
to which dingy responds by saying that he can
however he stops midway and realizes that he
cannots as the girl feeds and overjoyed dingy
he responds to her in ore by literally barking
like a puppy she then looks at denji somewhat in
disbelief that he can actually enjoy a soggy
udon as if he's really like a dog then she
blushes a little and asks the girl what her
name is to which she responds that her name
is makima visibly taken back at the beauty of
your name denji asks what kind of guy she's into
makima thinks for a moment and answers
telling him that it's people just like
him then she thinks to himself for a moment
somewhat confused and then says isn't that me
while danji thinks back on what makima had just
said he turns to her and goes to say that he likes
her as well but then realizes she isn't there
however makima calls him over and it is shown to
him that she has taken him to the devil hunters
tokyo headquarters it has explained through her
that there are over 1 000 devil hunters in
tokyo alone and that her bureau offers the
best staff but denji only thinks of what she said
earlier and starts imagining his future with her
makima gives denji a uniform telling him that
they normally work in one and after he changes she
would introduce him to his colleague after getting
changed makima introduces him to aki hayakawa
saying that starting today they are both partners
then she starts to complain hinting that he wants
to work with makima but before he can say
anymore aki drags him off while this happens
though makima walks up and tells him that if he
does well then they will be able to work together
while patrolling the streets aki tells denji
to follow him for a moment once making it to
the end of an alleyway aki beats him up punching
him in the face and kneeing him in the stomach
afterwards while lighting his smoke he
tells him to quit the devil hunter's bureau
he explains that people who became devil
hunters for weak reasons are the first to die
saying that only the devil hunter is still alive
that he's worked with are the ones with conviction
he instantly guesses correctly that denji only
became a devil hunter as he's interested in makima
as he finishes his smoke aki throws it onto
genji's chest and then proceeds to spit on it
to put it out he then turns and says that he will
tell makima that denji got scared and fearfully
run away however dinji instead hits him between
their legs taking him by surprise as he hits aki
he explains that today was the first day he felt
like a human and it was the first time someone had
treated him to a meal in his entire life he tells
him that if being a devil hunter for those reasons
is shallow then he'll die to keep things the way
they are right now aki stands up and fights back
tackling denji and continuing to punch him but
as he threw another punch he was once again hit
between the legs enraged then she screams at
him asking if it's because he also likes her
though aki was unable to reply and collapses onto
the floor stating that he really did only aim for
the balls returning to the headquarters dingy
says that aki got attacked by a testicle devil
but argue reveals that that was a lie makima asks
them if they'll get along with both of them giving
differing answers but makima decides to put them
in aki's experimental squad either way aki tries
to say that he doesn't need another weirdo as his
team has already filled with them but makima tells
him that his squad was meant to be experimental
which leaves aki confused wondering what dingy is
maki then explains that denji can turn into
a devil and stunned aki says that cases like
them are just myths but she says that he
is a special type and if he should ever run
or quit then he will be put down as a devil not
understanding the situation completely still then
she asks what she means and makima tells him that
it means that they will all be working together
until death do them part after leaving with aki
denji asks if makima is a good or a bad person
in hearing this aki tells him to be grateful that
at least he is still alive but as he still insists
on this question aki tells him that she definitely
is a good person as he owes her his life
as he says this then she remembers how she hugged
him then cheekily remarks on the melons that she
carries around with her which aki instantly
perks up at later on denji and aki start to
live together and the dream of the legendary bread
slice was completed but aki gets annoyed after
seeing the mess that dingy leaves around the house
and the amount of times that he had to use the
bathroom pushing him almost to the breaking point
before erupting though aki receives a call as
there is an appearance of a fiend in the eastner
meda residence after arriving at the location
they head towards the room to where they fiend
while heading there denji asks what a fein is
and aki explains that a fein is a devil that
has taken over a deceased body of a person
and are easily identified by their heads as they
see it he explains more that fiends take on the
hosting devil's personality aki commands denji to
kill the fein and show his devil power to prove
himself however then she decapitates and
kills the devil with a simple garden axe
before aki finished his sentence he goes on
to say to a confused aki that if he used his
power it would be a little overboard and he
wanted to give a painless death to the faint
archi gets angry and explains that things may
be half devils but they are still devils and he
shouldn't sympathise with them as they don't have
feelings like humans intensely aki tells him that
a devil killed his entire family right before
his eyes and those cops downstairs are his amaze
and they risk their lives every single day for
their wives and children everyone around them
is serious but dingy is not aki says that he wants
to kill devils in the most suffering way possible
and questions then she's morals when it comes to
befriending devils to which then she says that if
there are any devils that could be his friends
then he'll take them as he never had any before
however not impressed at his answer aki tells him
that he will remember that before leaving the room
as denji looked down he saw some of those melon
magazines and he then reveals that in reality he
didn't want to use his chainsaws as they will
spray blood all over his collectible manga he
then thinks to himself that he can now shower eat
tasty food and see a lovely lady almost every day
as well here's everything he ever wanted already
but feels like something is missing he notes that
aki's goal is revenge or something then curiously
wonders if makima has a dream of hers as well
and while thinking of her he comments that he
wants to touch some of her melons dingy then
realizes what he thought to be impossible is now
possible with his current life while he thinks
back on what aki said then she believes that
now he has found a serious dream and that is
to touch some of those beautiful melons now over
at the headquarters aki tells the delirious denji
to watch his mouth before mahima informs him
that she is pairing him up with a new partner
while dwelling over this thought makima explains
to him that they pair their agents up with new
partners for small-scale missions and patrols
once your friend does arrive though makima goes
to leave and warns him that she is a fame power
then makes her entrance telling all of the humans
to cower before her as she is called power then
she starts to wonder athens can be devil hunters
but as he sees her chest he quickly accepts it
and greets her as he gets excited to work with her
well that officially brings us to the very end
of my first video into chainsaw man and the
introduction arc of i guess you know obviously
chainsaw man in general this series is super
super dope and i'm super happy that i picked it
up before the anime did start releasing and i
honestly recommend that you guys do go ahead and
just start reading the series for yourself because
the mangaka foreign deserves so much praise
as well as in two of his series fire punch
and then this as well have both been absolute
stunners so i i can't wait as i said at the
start of the video to see what this guy puts out
in the future and i recommend that anyone go out
there and pick up his stuff honestly if you guys
have been wondering i've seen a lot of comments
asking where like kind of my tokyo revenge's uh
videos like this have been over the last month
or two on my channel and the next video that i am
going to be putting out is going to be my entire
tokyo avengers explained video for the uh latest
three deities arc of tokyo avengers obviously
main reason i haven't been making like reviews uh
in as much like a tokyo avengers stuff in general
anymore it's just for the fact that i've kind of
like been busy with making these videos they take
about two weeks sometimes to do one video alone
because they're an hour or two hours at a time
and reviewing things week by week can become you
know like quite repetitive at some points i know
it sounds as i said a little bit silly but that's
like one of the main reasons why and i like to
you know enjoy the series for the main reasons
that i got into it in the first place but anyway
i'm still enjoying it at how it is now and uh i
can't wait to you know kind of like talk about
it in my next video which i'm going to put out one
after that is going to be the jiu jitsu kaizen uh
hidden inventory arc explained and then i'll
probably do part two for this depending on how
you know well this video does so if you guys
have enjoyed this video and want to see you
know obviously part two for this or the bat
devil art i think it's the next dog i'm pretty
sure it is then make sure you leave a like and
obviously subscribe and leave a comment down
below and all that kind of jargon that i've
mentioned like four or five times already
but anyway for now it's been your professional
degenerate and i'll see you all but anyway for
now it's been your professional generic diavolo
and i will see you all in a birth bye you